[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 en el día mundial de la salud
más romeros a la un día para reflexionar
alrededor de que significa la salud para
nosotros y para el resto del mundo claro
es que a veces es un concepto que puede
ser algo esquivo no sabemos qué es la
salud cuando no la tenemos pero es muy
difícil definirla a veces en positivo y
de hecho esta es la crítica que se hacía
muchas veces a la medicina occidental la
salud como ausencia de enfermedad ir al
médico para que nos arreglen
puntualmente y seguir funcionando pero
de hecho ya desde los años 40 en la
constitución de la organización mundial
de la salud se define la salud como un
estado de completo bienestar físico
mental y social y explicitan no
solamente la ausencia de enfermedades
entonces partimos de aquí para
reflexionar alrededor de este concepto
entonces yo creo que en ese sentido
nadie está completamente sano marc esa
definición de completo sin estar
realmente es una visión compartida pues
en términos de definición o de concepto
pareciera que sí sin embargo a veces en
la práctica es algo distinto y eso nos
lo contaba oscar franco que es uno de
los accesos científicos de france 24 a
quien le preguntamos pues que era para
él la salud y pues nos contaba su
experiencia escuchemos lo
durante todo el tiempo que trabajaba en
investigación en academia me encuentro
con un sistema de salud que realmente no
está enfocado en la salud sino está
enfocado en la enfermedad y un manejo
médico y clínico de la salud que está
enfocado hacia eso hacia la enfermedad y
no hacia la salud la salud no es
simplemente una cuestión física o una
cuestión mental tiene mucho que ver con
la funcionalidad que tenemos dentro de
nuestra capacidad como seres humanos de
integrarnos de jugar un papel de jugar
el papel que queremos jugar dentro de la
sociedad de poder interactuar con la
gente que queremos en el medio ambiente
que que debemos que queremos vivir
es decir una reflexión con la que me
quedo de óscar franco es que esa salud
es aquello que nos permite al final
desarrollar la vida que queremos nuestro
querido doctor oscar francomar porque
otras maneras de entender la salud o la
medicina deberíamos tener nosotros en
cuenta pues hicimos también otra serie
de entrevistas a otras tradiciones
médicas de la salud también de la
sanación y una de esas visiones que
recogimos fue la visión desde la
medicina tradicional china escuchamos al
experto que entrevistamos
la salud en realidad
es una construcción como la construcción
de este
de la libertad es algo a desarrollar
entonces la salud es un proceso como
todo proceso se transita se va
aprendiendo
en general es entre opuestos
sacando un poco la medicina china de
gente que los puestos polares vigliano
y en ese abanico vamos transitando y
vamos aprendiendo
para sanarnos no
pues para mí la primera diferencia
quizás aquí es que la salud como tú
decías no es un estado en el que se está
o no se está que es lo de la definición
de la organización mundial de la salud
sino un proceso un continuo un
aprendizaje también de hecho nos
explicaba que desde la tradición china
también cada síntoma físico tiene algún
vínculo con síntomas también emocionales
mentales que se tratan pues a la par y
hablaba también de el equilibrio no yo
hago el resumen de la larga conversación
que tuvimos entre pues muchísimas cosas
y ese equilibrio es la salud del
desequilibrio es la enfermedad yo
concuerdo con esa visión es cien por
ciento más porque además es un proceso
digamos para encontrar toda esta salud
mental emocional pues del cuerpo como lo
define y como lo define la organización
mundial después sin duda es un proceso
pero repasemos ahora entonces a otra
cosmovisión esta vez en américa latina'
si entrevistamos a silvia hernández de
ella sanadora partera y líder
comunitaria del pueblo zapoteco pero
originario de oaxaca en méxico y esto
era lo que nos decía
la sanación es hacernos cargo de nuestro
propio cuerpo desde habitar cada célula
cada espacio y reconocer en nosotros
toda esa vida que está viva en nosotros
todo lo que nos está hablando dentro de
nosotros a veces es muy fácil escuchar
afuera lo que se está diciendo pero no
eres capaz de escuchar el dolor y qué
está diciendo el dolor es una decisión
de vida también ósea seguramente en
comunidades heridas en comunidades de
mucho dolor de mucho duelo que yo creo
que son muchas comunidades de todos los
pueblos originarios no solo juegos acá
sino del mundo
es una decisión y para que los pueblos
sigan viviendo y habitando lo sé y decir
yo soy zapoteca frente a que viven que
soy indígena y no lo soy no esté
este es como uno recobra su propio su
propia esencia y dice con esto quiero
caminar que lo que buscamos es estar
bien estar bien con tu corazón con tu
paz interna tanto equilibrio que le dice
muchas gracias a las plantas muchas
gracias a este día al amanecer entonces
silvia nos hablaba un poco de esta
decisión tanto individual también como
colectiva de decidir emprender este
proceso de sanar también de recuperar la
autonomía no en este caso para ellos
también pues de la propia tradición y
sabiduría ancestral y esa decisión sobre
los propios cuerpos y sobre la propia
comunidad yo me quedaría también con eso
no la salud no es algo que se pueda ver
desde una óptica individual sino que
pasa por la sociedad también y yo
también me quedaría amar pues con todo
esto que estamos viendo que la salud al
final es un equilibrio y un mundo
desequilibrado pues seguramente nosotros
vamos a estar sanos en algunos años y no
lo estamos por supuesto ahora para
terminar la salud también es un derecho
derecho que no lo tienen todos exacto no
quería terminar sin recordar esto es un
derecho que como bien decía se vulnera
repetidamente con falta de acceso a la
salud desigualdades que hacen que nos
enfermemos también y es un derecho que
además enlaza con muchos otros con el
derecho a la alimentación con el derecho
al agua a la educación al trabajo seguro
al final y para mí aquí es donde
confluyen todas estas definiciones que
hemos estado escuchando es un derecho
que garantiza que tengamos una vida que
merece ser vivida hablábamos del
equilibrio que han repetido todos una y
otra vez no dentro de nosotros con la
comunidad con el entorno y también con
el planeta de bienestar de la decisión
de tomar las riendas sobre el propio
cuerpo y sobre cómo queremos vivir en
comunidad al final todo esto nos habla
pues de poder existir de una manera
libre autónoma y plena algo que para mí
al final es la salud así es mari y pues
digamos que uno dice pues salud salud
salud pero ahorita analizando todo esto
con esta crónica me doy cuenta que tan
complicado es subir nuestra salud ha
sido muy difícil entender también un
poco como todas las aristas que tiene
esta palabra que al final la repetimos
todo el día qué y qué significado tiene
más muchísimas gracias entonces como
siempre mañana nos vemos con más de
salud aquí en directo américa pasamos a
saludar a nuestra segunda mitad del día